good afternoon the secretary general
will brief you uh on the extraordinary
meeting of the nato ukraine commission
and then we'll take a couple of
questions here in the room
and online secretary general
good afternoon we have just finished an
extraordinary meeting of the nato
ukraine commission
we condemn moscow's decision to
recognize the self-proclaimed donetsk
people's republic and luhansk people
republic
we also condemned the further russian
incursion into ukraine
moscow has now moved from covert
attempts to deep stabilized ukraine to
overturn military action
this is a serious escalation by russia
and a flagrant violation of
international law
it further undermines ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
it damages efforts to find a peaceful
resolution to the conflict
and has grave consequences for european
security
this is the crisis created by russia
alone
we commend ukraine for its restraint in
not responding to russia's repeated
provocations
we stand in solidarity with the
ukrainian people and its government
allies are united in their full support
for ukraine's sovereignty
and territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
we will continue to provide ukraine with
strong political support and allies are
providing equipment to help ukraine
defend itself as well as sustained
financial support
for months
russia has been building up a massive
military force in and around ukraine
including in belarus
with well over 150
000 troops
and fighter jets and attack helicopters
many units are now forward deployed in
combat formations
they are out of their camps in the field
and ready to strike
nato is resolute and united in its
determination to protect and defend all
allies
in the last weeks
allies have deployed thousands or more
troops to eastern part of the alliance
and placed more on standby
we have over 100 jets at high alert
and there are more than 120 allied ships
at the sea from the high north to the
mediterranean
we will continue to do whatever
is necessary to shield the alliance from
aggression
nato allies and the rest of the
international community
warned there would be a high cost of
russia carried out further aggressive
actions against ukraine
i welcome the economic sanctions
announced today by many nato allies
and the decision by the german
government that it cannot certify
the north stream to pipeline
we urge russia in the strongest possible
terms to choose the path of diplomacy
this is the most dangerous moment in
european security for a generation
but europe and north america continue to
stand strong together in nato united and
committed to defend and protect each
other
with that i'm ready to take your
questions
okay uh we'll go to ukraine form
dimitri's
here
national news agency of ukraine as nato
has quite transparent policy in the
situational assessment could you please
share the vision uh have you discussed
with ukrainian side of the
uh possibility that russian troops would
not stop on the contact line and will
be moving deeper at least to the
administrative borders of the lugansk
and the niska areas and what will be the
reaction of nato in that regard and the
follow-up question if i may
what is your assessment how high is
still a risk
of a
false flag operation from russian side
thank you
every indication
is that russia
continues to plan
for a full-scale attack on ukraine
we see the ongoing military buildup
they promised to step back but they had
continued to step up
we see that more and more of the forces
are moving out of the camps and are in
combat formations and ready to strike
and we see the ongoing provocations in
donbass
and the different false flag operations
where they tried to create a pretext for
an attack and then of course we saw last
night
that a further russian troops moved into
donbass
into
parts of donetsk and luhansk
and then we have the threatening
rhetoric which was actually confirmed in
the speech of president putin
yesterday at the same time it's never
too late it's never too late to not
attack
and that's reason why we continue to
call on russia to
step
back to de-escalate
and to engage in good faith in
diplomatic
efforts to find a political solution
if russia decides once again to use
force against ukraine there will be even
stronger sanctions even a higher price
to pay
allies continue to provide support to
ukraine and in the meeting with ukraine
today many allies pledged continued
support financial support to
support military support
and also nato provides uh critical
support to help ukraine strengthen its
cyber defenses
uh and of course nato's uh
main responsibility is to make sure that
there is
no aggression against any nato allied
countries so we have already increased
our presence in the eastern part
alliance and we're ready to further
increase our presence in the eastern
part of alliance if necessary
associated press
thank you mark carlson associated press
you consider russia's latest movements
an invasion of ukraine
i think we have to recall that
russia has already invaded ukraine they
invaded ukraine back in 2014 they
annexed the part of ukraine crimea and
since 2014 there have been
russian military
units forces in donbass in donetsk and
luhansk
so what we see now is that a country
which is already invaded
is suffering further invasion
and the and with more
russian military presence and this is of
course
even more serious because
because
this comes on on top of
the recognition of these so-called
people's republics in donetsk and
luhansk so what we see is
further invasion of a country which is
already invaded
we'll now go online to greg palket from
fox news
thanks very much juana and thank you uh
secretary general i i really have to be
precise about this because
there's been a bit of a confusion you
say last night further russian troops
entered the donbass do you have evidence
that russian troops vehicles men
gear have moved from russian territory
into
well it's really ukrainian territory but
it's the occupied dumbass do you have
evidence of that and if so
that is an invasion correct and if so
have you changed your posture at all but
but specifically about that point do you
have evidence that new russian troops
have moved from russia
into the dumbass that is the occupied
territory of ukraine
yes uh and i think again we have to
understand that russia has been in
donbass for many years since 2014
but that has been in in a
covert operation where they have denied
their presence
but this so-called separatist has been
controlled by and supported by
russian troops russian special special
oppression
personnel
for many many years so russia has been
present in different covert operations
in donetsk and france
for many many years what we see now is
additional russian forces and troops
moving in
um and and this makes the whole
situation even more serious this is a
step change
and then this is combined with
the
recognition
of these territories which are inside
the international recognized borders of
ukraine as independent states so this is
adding fuel this is making it more
dangerous and more serious and uh
and then on top of that we also see that
continued russian military buildup and
preparation for a larger scale attack on
ukraine
okay we'll go to nicola barrot
from le figaro
you'll need to unmute yourself
do you hear me um can you give us a
precise view on the military forces and
assets that are deployed by russia near
the border and in donbass and the forces
from the desperatist you you talked
about um 150 000 truths but could be
more precise thanks
well what i can say is that russia has
well over 150 000 troops uh in addition
to that of course there are air forces
and naval forces also close to ukraine
uh and these forces are uh partly inside
ukraine already in crimea and in donbass
uh and partly close to ukraine's borders
uh both in the in the in the east uh uh
but also in the south uh
and also uh in the north partly in
russia and partly in in belarus
and these forces are combated
tens of thousands of combat troops but
also
all kinds of enablers um
missiles
armored vehicles battle tanks drones
for electronic warfare
uh air defense iskandar missiles which
are actually dual capable missiles
and a wide range of different military
capabilities so this is a force
which is not only strong and well
equipped and have a a lot of high end
capabilities but it's also force which
is now um fully uh resourced with
ammunition and fuel and then uh more and
more of the troops have moved out of
their camps and now are are now in the
in the position where they can uh attack
without any warning time so of course
this makes the whole situation very
dangerous
but as we have stated again and again
russia still has a choice
to choose diplomacy to step back
and to engage in a political dialogue
with nato allies and we have
demonstrated over a long period of time
that we are ready to sit down
to
to to
talk to the russian good faith
uh on issues which also matters for
their security arms control
transparency and many other issues
we'll go to terry schultz from national
public radio
hi thank you very much for taking our
remote questions uh mr secretary general
um
do you worry that uh
that russia is uh declaring that it will
also recognize this sovereignty um you
can can't see my fingers over parts of
of ukraine that are currently controlled
by
ukrainian forces that seems that it
would it would make the the probability
of conflict a lot higher and with the
baltic states and other uh other
neighboring allies calling for yet more
support even more than nato has done so
far
what more can you do right now
practically not what you've done so far
but what more can you do in the very
near future in the next days to reassure
those nervous allies
what you have seen is a bit mixed
signals from moscow on whether they have
recognized the territory between the
russian border and the contact line
or recognized as
donetsk and luhansk people's republics
the whole territory of the two oblasts
but anyway this is a step change this is
further increasing the threats
and the violation of
ukraine's territorial integrity and the
sovereignty just a fact that have
recognized these entities
as independent states
and that's the reason why we condemn it
so clearly
and also the reason why
we welcome the sanctions that
nato allies today
in different formats have decided to
impose and also i welcome the decision
by germany to
stop the
the approval of the north stream to
project
um
we have already increased our presence
in the baltic states
um we did so after a trend
after the illegal annexation of crimea
in 2014
and we also done it over the last weeks
and months
then we have plans in place we have
forces available to reinforce further if
needed we will do that in a defensive
way
our purpose is to prevent the conflict
is to reassure
allies and of course nato's core
responsibility is to make sure that
there is no room for any miscalculation
about our commitment to protect and
defend allies and but that also prevent
any attack on any allied
country
for the next question we'll go to jeff
shogo from task and purpose
thank you mr secretary general has the
nato response force been activated if so
how many troops are deploying to europe
thank you
the nato response force
has
been put on higher readiness we've done
we did that several weeks ago
but it has not been deployed
uh what we have deployed are other units
of uh from nato allied countries
the united states has deployed troops
and forces in europe i met some of them
in romania a few days ago
germany has deployed more troops to
lithuania the united kingdom has doubled
its presence in in estonia
with the battlegroup there
and other allies um including
spain the netherlands denmark
and many others have decided to send in
troops ships and planes to reinforce our
presence and france has also made it
clear that they are ready to lead a
battlegroup in
in romania so
so far we have increased the readiness
of the nato response force
but we are not deployed the nato
response force
thank you for the next question we'll go
to ketavan cardava from emedi tv
hello
good evening
uh thank you anna mr secretary general
latest news from russia putin asks
lawmakers for permission to use force
outside russia could pave the way for
broader attack on ukraine how would you
comment on
this issue and also yesterday putin
spoke a lot about nato expansion and you
know that with ukraine georgia is also
waiting for future membership and and
such statements are so worried for us
what is your comment and is it possible
[Music]
and acceptable
about what putin was talking two days
ago so-called moratorium on nato
expansion
thank you so much
a request
to
get permission to use
force outside the russian territory
just adds to the pattern
of
decisions and actions by russia over the
last months
which has led to the most dangerous
moment for our security in decades and
this just and this is just another step
i think we have to recall that actually
nato and nato allies um
uh warned this fall that
we saw uh military build up by russia
and plans
uh to reach a level of russian forces in
around ukraine which is very much where
we are today so this this is this is
something that has been predicted many
months ago and then russia has done what
we expected
and what we warned against
they have significantly
increased their military presence in
around ukraine and then combined with
and and all the
and all the
false flag operations the attempts to
create a pretext
and now
yesterday the
recognition of the people's republics of
donetsk and luhansk
all of that adds into
this pattern of uh threatening and
aggressive behavior and any permission
to use force outside the russian
territory just
adds to
that pattern
um filament it doesn't change our
message and that is that we continue to
call on russia to step
back not to continue to step up as we've
seen over the last
weeks
but also
that they
engage in real diplomatic efforts
nato has made it clear that we are ready
to talk
and we have listed
in
letters or in a letter we have sent to
russia but also the united states has
conveyed
a document to russia in parallel with
nato where we list in many areas we were
ready to sit down discuss
and try to find a political path forward
but in that document we also made it
clear that we will not compromise on
core values um and one of them is of
course the right for every nation to
choose its own path
um nato enlargement has been
extremely important for europe over many
decades it helps to spread democracy
freedom across europe for decades after
the end of the cold war
and we will
neither compromise our right to protect
and defend all allies when russia is
demanding that we should sign a legally
binding agreement
to
remove all nato infrastructure and all
native forces from
the territories of those
allies that joined the alliance after
1997 we can not accept that because that
will be
the same as to say that um we will
introduce some kind of first and second
class nato membership where we don't
have the same right to protect those
allies that joined after 1997
so we will not compromise on those
principles but we are ready to
engage in political dialogue on many
important issues which are also
important for
the security of russia
for the last question we'll go to doug
blooded and braga di
hi uh people around the world and
especially in europe are now afraid of a
full-on war what do you think of that
fair and
how far away are we
as there is a real risk
and that's exactly why we have been
warning against these four months
and regrettably what we have seen over
the last months is that exactly what we
predicted has happened but it's still
possible for russia
to change course and to
not continue the military buildup and
not invade
further
ukraine
[Music]
i think also that we need to
to realize that um
ukraine is a highly valued partner we
support them
uh
with military support with uh with
political support with the cyber
defenses with equipment different allies
provide different types of support
but when it comes to
nato allies we provide
absolute security guarantees meaning
that we
make it absolutely clear that the attack
on one ally will trigger the response
from the whole alliance one for all all
for one
and uh and that's also the reason why
nato has increased its presence in
eastern part of the alliance in the
defensive manner
to make sure that there is no room
for miscalculation about our ability to
defend all allies and as long as we do
that
we will
we will prevent an attack on nato allied
countries